bonjour à tous bon jour à tout ce soir
j'aimerais parler d'un sujet qui me
fascine en fait j'ai toujours été
fascinée de manière générale par les
gens qui font des trucs des gens qu'ils
accomplissent les gens qui construisent
les gens qui entreprennent de manière
générale et pas que des boîtes je parle
des artistes je parle des sportifs par
des gens qui font des choses
exceptionnelles dans leur vie ça m'a
toujours fasciné ça m'a toujours attiré
j'ai toujours voulu être un peu plus
proche de ces gens là à tel point que
j'en ai fait mon métier et
qu'aujourd'hui je vois passer des
centaines et des centaines
d'entrepreneurs tous les jours certains
ont du succès certaines ont du succès
certains en ont moins
et je renvoie surtout beaucoup qui ont
des blocages et qui savent pas par où
commencer ou qui ont déjà bien avancé
qui savent pas comment continuer et
j'essaie constamment de comprendre ce
qui les bloque et de comprendre ce qui
fait qu'il n'arrive pas à entreprendre
et à aller plus loin et à accomplir
leurs rêves
et pour vous expliquer un petit peu ce
que j'ai conclu de ces dernières années
d'observation avec tous ces
entrepreneurs
je vais vous raconter une petite
histoire mon histoire donc ça c'est moi
à 12 ans j'ai un peu changé
bonne blague je passe beaucoup beaucoup
de temps dans la chambre j'ai mes
parents avec son ordi à coder à faire
pas mal de trucs je suis un peu un geek
un peu beaucoup et j'aime vraiment ça
j'aime vraiment l'informatique et ça me
différencier un petit peu des autres et
j'ai toujours envie d'être différent des
autres
et puis à force de tribus les et de
passer du temps sur internet et décoder
et d'apprendre toutes ces choses je fini
par tomber sur un mec qui est un peu une
copie de moi qui est assez proche de moi
dans sa personnalité dans son personnage
et je trouve ça intéressant la seule
différence entre lui et moi c'est que
lui il a beaucoup beaucoup de succès
cette personne c'est mark zuckerberg
[Musique]
il a vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
succès mark zuckerberg il a créé
facebook dans une chambre à harvard sur
son ordi aujourd'hui facebook c'est une
boîte qui vaut 550 milliards de dollars
et qui est utilisé par plus de 2
milliards de personnes dans le monde
chaque jour une belle histoire
et puis du coup forcément tu
t'identifies tu es dans ta jambe sur ton
ordi à coder tu dis si lui l'a fait moi
aussi je peux le faire et puis on trouve
d'autres et à larry page et sergey brink
qui sont les fondateurs de google qui
eux ils n'ont pas créé dans une chambre
mais dans un garage
donc c'est la même histoire dans la
silicon valley ils ont créé google car
un moteur de recherche qui vaut
aujourd'hui 777 milliards de dollars et
qui utilisait part parce que la moitié
des gens dans le monde
incroyable elon musk qui a fait atterrir
la première fusée qui avait décollé une
fois et qui a pu atterrir sans dommages
qui à la base est né en afrique du sud
est grâce au pouvoir d'internet et de
l'informatique a réussi à s'élever à
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui un des meilleurs
entrepreneurs de notre ère tous ces gens
là hormis le fait que ce soit tous des
hommes blancs ce qui est un autre sujet
ils sont inspirants et on raconte des
histoires sur eux beaucoup et on raconte
de très très belles histoires
à tel point que moi du haut de mes 12
ans derrière mon ordi je me suis dit je
pouvais faire partie de cette catégorie
de personnes là et ça nous amène à notre
premier problème
le premier problème quand on veut
entreprendre quand on veut accomplir des
choses dans notre vie c'est être
entrepreneur c'est devenu sexy et
accessible pourquoi pas ce qu'on peut en
parler tout le temps on peut on peut
raconter des histoires et ces histoires
elles ont toujours la même structure est
le vrai problème c'est qu'on va essayer
quand on quand on commence à
entreprendre on va essayer de reproduire
cette structure pour avoir le même
succès que les personnes que j'ai évoqué
juste avant cette structure c'est celle
là elle est toujours décomposée en trois
temps d'abord je vais créer quelque
chose de fou ensuite je vais le faire
connaître au monde entier et ensuite
j'ai kiffé je vais profiter
je vais peut-être faire d'autres trucs
avec l'argent la notoriété que j'aurais
accumuler
le problème de ce schéma là hormis le
fait qu'il soit complètement faux c'est
que dès la première étape
tu peux rester coincé complètement parce
qu'en fait tu tombes dans un cycle
infini où tu essayes de créer quelque
chose de fou le problème c'est que
quelque chose de fou ça ne veut rien
dire et qu'on peut toujours trouver une
petite idée en plus qui fait qu on se
dit ah ah ça ce serait encore plus vous
ce serait incroyable et donc en fait on
se retrouve dans une espèce de cercle
vicieux géant on se dit tout le temps à
si je faisais quelque chose d'un peu
plus si on crée un produit par exemple
si on crée un un logiciel ou un site web
si jamais on arrive à casser ce cycle et
à finir par essayer d'aller chercher du
bout des doigts
la deuxième étape ça se passe comme ça
tu mets un post sur ton facebook où tu
dis dans trois jours je vais lancer ma
nouvelle start-up être super le monde
entier est derrière son écran en train
d'attendre la nouvelle start-up de
valentin régeard et puis en fait non pas
tout à fait se passe pendant ces trois
jours il se passe tout un tas de choses
tout un tas d'émotions qui défilent dans
ta tête
la principale c'est de l'anxiété c'est
l'anxiété parce que tu te dis ok j'ai
passé six mois à créer quelque chose de
fou est ce que le monde va reconnaître
cette chose comme étant quelque chose
d'incroyable ou pas étant quand même un
pressentiment que non et puis le jour du
lancement
ça y est c'est parti à start up est
lancé le travail que tu fournis depuis
six mois va être enfin découvert par le
monde et dans la plupart des cas ça
fonctionne pas et le problème c'est que
tu te retrouves avec tes rêves brisés
terrible tu te retrouves en fait
apparaître avec un seul truc qui est à
créer quelque chose de pas si fou
finalement et que ça fait mal et c'est
très très compliqué la solution à ce
problème à ces histoires qu'on raconte
c'est de comprendre que le voyage est
plus important que la destination est
qu'en fait tout ce qu'on crée en tant
qu'entrepreneur on peut le vivre de
manière exaltante
je vais préciser sur ce point là le
deuxième problème dont j'aurais envie de
parler par rapport à l'entrepreneuriat
c'est qu'entreprendre c'est une série de
décisions difficiles à prendre
si le chemin il est pas en trois étapes
quand je voulais montrer jusqu'à
maintenant à quoi il ressemble le chemin
j'ai essayé le conceptualiser pour vous
montrer un petit peu pour moi il
ressemble à ça du coup forcément il est
un petit peu plus compliqué c'est
difficile de raconter en gros en bleu
vous avez toutes les phases dans
l'entrepreneuriat vous fait de
l'observation vous rassembler des
données pour comprendre comment
fonctionne le marché et pour pouvoir
ensuite agir en fonction c'est les
phases rouge et phase d'action
l'entrepreneuriat c'est à alterner
constamment entre observation et actions
le problème c'est que dans une histoire
entrepreneuriale
ce schéma là quand tu es au début
j'étais tout seul dans ta chambre ça
ressemble à ça puis quand tu commences à
faire grossir sa boîte ça ressemble à ça
et quand et facebook ça ressemble plus à
ça et c'est pour ça qu'on raconte jamais
cette histoire parce qu'elle est un rat
comptable et qu'on oublie les trois
quarts des choses qui sont passés dans
le cycle entrepreneurial au fur et à
mesure qu'on crée des boîtes si on se
concentre sur une étape prenons la
première la première étape d'une boîte
très souvent c'est observer le marché et
ensuite de créer une solution simple à
un problème entre les deux entre
l'observation est l'action il ya
toujours la même chose il ya une
décision cette décision au départ elle
est simple parce que tu es tout seul
parce que finalement tu es assez libre
de ses mouvements
le problème c'est que plus on avance
dans la vie d'une boîte plus le passage
de l'observation à l'action est
compliqué parce que la décision se
multiplient potentiellement tu vas
devoir recruter des gens potentiellement
tu vas devoir choisir des technologies
potentiellement tu vas devoir choisir
une stratégie et tout un tas de choses
qui font que le chemin entrepreneuriale
de manière générale se complexifie et à
grande échelle et sur une longue période
de temps
ça devient incompréhensible complètement
c'est extrêmement difficile de raconter
ça maintenant dans ce graphique là il ya
toutes les parties bleu et rouge
correspondent en fait à des compétences
à des choses qu'on fait observer le
marché il ya des manières de le faire
des bonnes manières de le faire des
moins bonnes manières de le faire
créer un produit et des bonnes manières
de le faire et c'est moi ce qui
m'intéresse dans l'entreprenariat et qui
est commun à tous les entrepreneurs et à
toutes les entrepreneurs que j'ai pu
voir c'est uniquement les décisions
entre les deux le problème c'est que
personne voit le chemin entrepreneuriale
comme ça encore une fois et que la
solution
ah ça c'est qu'il faut prendre des
décisions le plus rapidement possible et
le plus efficacement possible
constamment le problème de ça le
problème de devoir prendre des décisions
vite et efficacement c'est qu'on se
rappelle toujours de cette étape-là du
moment où tu as créé quelque chose de
pas si fou et ton ego après un coût
gigantesque puis bon je pense qu'on
pourrait être un peu pour être
entrepreneur il faut un minimum d'ego et
ça fait même très très mal quand on se
rappelle de ça et qu'on essaye de
prendre une décision et qu'on se dit que
potentiellement on va arriver de nouveau
au même résultat
c'est très très difficile et donc
prendre des décisions devient compliqué
et on fait ce que tous les êtres humains
sur cette planète font quand ils doivent
prendre des décisions difficiles dans
leur vie
on cherche la validation des autres ça
m'amène à mon troisième point quelques
très peu de personnes malheureusement
qui donne des bons conseils
quand on est entrepreneur pourquoi parce
que déjà les gens ont toujours un
intérêt
ta famille votre protégé des amis
veulent te faire plaisir et des
potentiels clients ils veulent que tu
leur foute la paix grosso modo et le
problème c'est que donc on peut pas
aller demander de l'aide à ce jour là
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait on va demander
de l'aide aux gens qui veulent bien nous
la donner et ils se décomposent toujours
en deux catégories
et c'est assez fou parce que les gens
pensent tout le temps savoir quoi faire
à ta place tu as vraiment d'autres types
de personnes tu as les gens qui vont
imaginer et fantasmé ce que tu fais la
situation dans laquelle tu es et qui se
disent oui les entrepreneurs c'est
incroyable mois sa place je sais
exactement quoi faire et toi t'es
complètement paralysé plus est les
autres qui sont les gens qui l'ont déjà
fait a longtemps et qu'il vente directe
tu sais moi mon temps j'ai fait comme ça
et ça a marché
le problème c'est qu'ils prennent pas en
compte l'aspect le plus important d'une
prise de décision et d'un cycle
entrepreneuriale qui est qu'il faut
s'adapter au contexte est quelqu'un qui
a créé une boîte ya 70 ans le contexte
était radicalement différent et même
quelqu'un qui a créé une boîte ya trois
ans le contexte était aussi très très
différents et en fait il peut pas vous
donner des bons conseils
c'est quasiment impossible la solution à
ce problème c'est qu'il faut s'entourer
de gens qu'ils font en même temps que
toi ou qui ont peut-être une toute
petite longueur d'avancé parce que c'est
facile de s'inspirer de ces gens là ils
viennent de passer une étape à laquelle
tu es confronté
tu te dis bon ok je vais faire la même
chose tu peux copier tu peux essayer
c'est facile de se raccrocher à des gens
qui sont proches de toi il faut il faut
essayer de s'entourer de ces gens là
alors avant de terminer j'aimerais vous
inviter
à faire la chose je pense qui est la
plus importante dans une vie qui est de
se poser les bonnes questions quelles
décisions vous avez prises récemment si
vous voulez entreprendre si vous voulez
devenir artiste si vous voulez créer une
boîte si vous voulez devenir sportif peu
importe quelle décision que vous avez
prise récemment et à ce qu'elle avait un
vrai impact sur votre vie et sur votre
chemin sur votre cheminement est ce que
vous êtes allé au bout de l'exécution de
ces décisions
ou est ce que vous vous êtes retrouvé
dans une situation vous êtes dit je
prends une décision c'est parti j'y vais
à fond deux jours plus tard ah ouais
mais en fait il ya peut-être une autre
décision meilleur donc à je vais
recommencer à zéro
et puis c'est un cycle éternel de
nouveau posez vous aussi la question de
savoir est ce que les gens qui vous
entourent vous pousse dans cette
direction vous pousse à prendre des
décisions le plus vite et le plus
efficacement possible
et est ce qui vous pousse à aller au
bout de ses décisions et à construire la
vie que vous avez envie d'avoir
et surtout la question la plus
importante pour moi je pense qu'elle
peut le devenir pour vous ce sera quoi
la prochaine décision
qu'est ce qu'on va faire juste après
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]